when i'm walking this is what i'm trying
to do to be the best
the best
investor the best incubate incubator i
can be
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by jayvengers a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance opposed labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serona partners and in media partnership
with ctec
welcome to 20 minute leaders another
really exciting episode because it's
different and today we're in the negev
of israel in the desert talking about
innovation and talking about how the
startup ecosystem can transcend
geographical barriers and today we're
talking about in a gif with amir tzap
vice president of investments in
business development at negev incubator
which invests in promising ventures in
the fields of climate tech foodtech
agritech
prior to that amir was an investment
banking manager leading major
transactions also as a student he was
the president of the student board of
the management school in the hebrew
university meet amir
amir
welcome to 20 minute leaders thank you
very very much for joining me how are
you thank you for having me i'm very
well how are you
i'm i'm doing well thank you and you
know we're looking at the startup
ecosystem and when we're looking at the
negev and we're looking at the
government and the israel innovation
authority and and the world of
accelerators so a lot for us to unpack
today
uh about your work with inagiev as a
vice president of of investments and biz
dev and and and you know a lot of
different
layers to understand you know the
important work that you do for the
ecosystem here
and a fascinating journey simply about
you know where you're where where you
are and what you do there so amir thank
you very much for joining me
thank you thank you and negev is a very
inspiring and kind of my dream my dream
job
and also good
creating good
by
good companies and
and developing the ecosystem in the
negative so what can be better
so so you know the phrase dream job i i
don't take that lightly and yeah i you
know it's an amazing sentence to be said
about the work the place that you're
working
why is this your dream job
honestly you know it's it's such a
cliche but someone says if you work
every day but you're not feeling like
you're working that's the dream job that
that's what i'm doing i'm kind of like
you
and meeting fascinated people meeting
entrepreneurs
uh
surrounding with the brilliant minds of
israel and the negev by creating an
impel impact and moving the needle in
israel
so the connection to the negev where
does that come from for you
um
honestly for me negev i have to say
because i originally born and raised in
jerusalem now i'm living in tel aviv and
i'm starting the enego project about
three years ago
when we went to the tender and
myself and
we tried to establish the whole energy
the whole negative ecosystem to
to create something new that invest in
the climate tech in audiotech and
foodtech you need a
4.0 by bringing together also financial
investors and also strategic investors
in that industry in industrial
industrial players
and also
ttos which tech stands for tech
technology tech transfer offices
and
and we did it together in
in
three years ago and that's my passion
this is where my passion comes from
so maybe take me 30 000 feet in the air
and a bit more you know with a germ more
generalistic view about what's happening
today in the ecosystem
why is it even a special thing to say
that we have an accelerator in the
negative
so apologize if i want to correct you
it's an incubator an incubator sorry
yeah and
it's just it's a special thing because
if you look at the demographic of israel
and the people who work in the high tech
only three percent of the high-tech
workers in israel come from the negative
region and this is what we're dealing
with right so we need to
move the needle and take these
presenters a lot higher
not not to 20 but it will do if it will
be 10
then it's okay not just for a negative
as an israel policy
um
and this is
where the negev and such other
accelerators come about because we are
trying to
attack it from the beginning to create
to create and surround all of the this
ecosystem and all on all of this from
fragmented players who doesn't really
communicate it with each other up until
recently
to start working together to create an
ecosystem it's not exactly as well as it
happens in tel aviv san francisco and
other places in the world
so how do you actually go about doing
that and achieving that growth from
three percent to ten percent what needs
to happen and how do you actually do it
okay so
we we take a lot of actions
first of all by being an investor right
we are especially investing because we
are not just investing in companies
seeing people we are actually creating
companies we are venture builders
so we try to take we are coming to these
ttos and research institute
with uh
problems that we know from the in that
from industrial players such as
a netafem and sodastream who are part of
our shareholders
and but not not only them others other
players in israel and other industrial
players in israel and
worldwide
and we try to attack these problems
and we take it by by seeing them in the
in academia once we
we see this potential we started to
build the venture around it
we have uh advisors we are bringing ceos
we're making founders and so on and
creating from this
from this seed
company this is one thing we do we also
we also have
put emphasis a big emphasize of uh
education
and trying to be and trying to
and
take
other part of the israel society doesn't
come into light when you think about the
high-tech citizens such as the bedouin
systems
to the height to this to this
accelerator and incubator so we are
promoting and helping and mentoring
bedwing accelerators
but you know more tangibly the process
of you know incubating and you corrected
me before but you know the difference
between incubation and acceleration is
different you know in incubation
you have to you know not just um
accelerate the progress a process that
started but you actually have to to
ignite the process and plant the seed
sure you know what actually happens in
in negev how do you actually go about
finding the right teams putting them
together and finding the right ideas for
them to work on
so this is the secret sauce
and this is very very difficult and
honestly this is a very difficult job
but what we what we do is
we are very lucky right as a negative
because like i said we are having
financial investor in our shareholders
and also industrial industrial investors
so which we sit with them on almost a
week or even not even at the daily basis
about their stylist about their problems
of tomorrow
and we are sitting with not only them
with
icl or nestle
and strauss or other big companies in
the climate climate
scene
and trying to attack these problems once
we understand the problems we go to the
research institute and try to to see
what is their solution for these
problems and when you say research
institute is this uh universities
researchers
universities researchers in the negative
there's a lot of agriculture thing right
so there's like
research institute
college institute uh
a lot of them together and trying to get
all these anchors that are in the negev
and
and to utilizing them and their know-how
into companies and one once we see that
and they say okay there's a product
there's a there's a venture technology
there's a product market fit
now this is the first step the second
step is trying to establish the team
around it
and the market around it with the
industry and advisory board that will
help us it will help us to create it we
are doing most of the job that we need
to do
and before we invest in it take us six
approximately for between four months to
six months to invest in the company
and and how much would that be invest
would they an investment there be from
any give
between 300 dollars to 600
and we're trying to build this as a
round right
so that would be that would concert to
more of a precedent round of between
three hundred thousand two seconds
where you would be contributing to that
round and guessing with other strategic
angels and other investors correct sure
sure that's true and and so to tell me
you know a few maybe specific case
studies of what's been happening you've
mentioned that this has been going on
for a few years now so what's what's
been happening with the negev until now
what things that you know to just paint
a more a clear picture
in my mind
so
we won the tender in
we started two years ago and we started
operating one and a half years ago 18
months ago
and i think one of the first project we
saw it was a project from ben gurion now
it's called big commerce
i met the
the researcher and and honestly fell in
love with the project because
it's a
it's a semi-robot hand robot that helped
in picking uh less while picking of uh
stock and warehouses that's a big
problem today right because it's still a
manpower job and you need to you need to
replace it
we put we didn't put this project in one
of the
bengal university
accelerators which which we also promote
and what in a partner of we founded the
we connected between the the ceo to seo
great ceo actually from the center of
israel to this company
to the two commerce and now
i think two two three months ago we
actually invested in the company so it
took us a lot of time
to create this environment but now this
company
has
17 employees
and
college uh students from the university
that wanted not all of them from the
chevrolet region some of them of israeli
center they want to stay and and be full
part full part employees in the
companies you're gonna come in this
company we have connected them with
a lot of players big big big names like
apology but i can't mention their names
to have pilots with them in the in this
year and now we are starting the next
round this is one example another good
great example is they come is a spin-off
of the company that came from belsheva
in the fields of
new alternative proteins
the these companies in in the medical
devices
and actually pharma grade
company and they have a spin-off to
alternative protein they came to us
because from some form from the
ecosystem
listen you know how to build this not us
let's let's they have a and licensing
agreement and the technology is yours
this is what i'm working on until now so
this is two two great great examples for
what we're doing on a daily basis
and so how many companies have gone
through the program and
and so sort of what is the structure
like in the vision for this
okay so
up until now we have um
five portfolio companies and three three
more to go in the next two months
and we want to invest in
30 30 to 40 companies until the end of
our license which is in four months four
years from now
what does that mean the end of the
license from the israel innovation
authority so okay so
the iaa which promotes innovation in
israel and
announced the
tender
three years ago to invest in uh to build
incompetence than the periphery
the it was a highly competitive bid
because there was no specific theme
but you needed to promote
specific region that you are
operating in by taking all of the
anchors together and utilizing utilizing
them into an ecosystem that working
together
and
there was three
um winners us which came in first
eiffel valley in the galilee and another
one in the negev which invests more in
cannabis in cannabis tech
and
this is the and the license was for five
years and we have four movies to go so
what does that what does it actually
mean to get the license so how does this
actually operate and and what is sort of
your
responsibility towards israel innovation
authority what is the responsibility
towards you
so it means that you have a partner
which is the ia and the ia um
helping you
to
lay down the grounds for you to do
the great job that you were assigned to
do
and also that every company that we want
to invest in that needs to be approved
by the ia which is great thing because
the i am have the most notable
researchers and advisors that israel
have had
they are a great great great great i
can't emphasize it enough great partner
for us
phenomenal and uh once we have you know
the iaa as a partner here in this regard
you know is that so i guess what they're
interested in is to see more startups
from the periphery is that that's their
goal right their vision true
and so your what is sort of your how do
they measure you
so in other words if i if i were to ask
the iaa
what is sort of the kpi of in a give
what what what is you know what is at
the end is it the number of startups
that come out is it you know getting an
exit from the negev what is you know
what is really the the goal here they
want to see in a high number of
companies that stay and operate in the
negative region and this is what you're
trying to do
that these companies once they be mature
will stay in the neighbor
we can force them to do it but that's
this is why i'm saying
utilizing the
the um ankles in the in the negative
region
because by utilizing them you can
provide them a solid one to stay and not
just by forcing them because
this is our kpi honestly
so so what i'm understanding what i'm
understanding from this is that what you
you know what what
what they're saying is that you know
we're less interested about the
immediate
short-term benefits but we're looking to
create an ecosystem here which is
self-sufficient which is anchored in the
roots of the negative and is not looking
to just create companies and then move
to the center but create an ecosystem
which can support its internal companies
as well right
sure
what else needs to happen in your eyes
in order to continue promoting that
because it sounds like you
as in they give our you know a piece of
a puzzle
that you know of you know the nation
that is trying to promote innovation
down there where you know what what else
needs to happen in the next few years in
your opinion to continue promoting this
mission and vision
um
the things that are made to happen
actually are happening right because
bengali university are investing a lot
in
building and startups and technology and
transforming these technologies into
evaluate startups
in bengal a lot of investors are putting
their eyes on them and the potential in
the negev
and there is amanda israeli
um intelligent forces that are moving to
the negative region meaning that the
negative will enjoy
um
a great manpower that can stay here and
promote the negative so all of these
things together are putting all the
negative vision as a whole and negative
as you rightfully and noted is a piece
in this puzzle in
the right place to go
to to do this next slip that we all all
hoping for
how do you
know your cell phone
get into incubation and startup
incubation how does one find themselves
you know working on on incubating many
startups we've incubated five startups
already three more on the way
how does one find themselves doing that
um
honestly i'm still trying to get to
figure it out why because my background
is investment banking big m a's and ipos
in israel
before i was in a negev and
once my first bond was
we had my firstborn alma i decided that
i need to
need some break for my previous job
and
the guys that are trying to to establish
their the
the negative company 20 minutes and
listen we need some help uh and going
into the standard and
and i said
okay
interesting but it's not really my
expertise and tell me listen we want you
we know what you we know what we're
doing
trust us it would be okay and honestly i
fell in love with the negative
this is how it happened so
yeah i was in the right place in the
right time i understand
the right place at the right time and
and then i think that there you know
there's a lot of uh there's also
inspiration to be taken from you know
the way that you're that you're looking
at your job and the way that you're that
you're acting on it and so even before
investment being king amir you know
thinking about you you as a kid and you
know roaming the world what you know
what were you really fascinated by what
really sparked your curiosity
basketball basketball on a huge michael
jordan junkie i'm still i'm still
looking at
all the videos i've seen on youtube i
watched really that's then for
actually
what is it what is it about uh what is
it about michael that you know really
inspires you
his drive to win
is like no other his passion to the game
and his
is
when you say to someone he's michael
jordan off it's the high
couple the highest accomplishment you
can give to someone right
and this is
when i'm walking this is what i'm trying
to do to be the best
the best uh investor the best incubate
incubator i can be and this is what i
love
thank you very much both for these 20
minutes but also for the great work
you're doing for israel and the negev
and it sounds like a fascinating work
that changes a lot
and it sounds like you are enjoying it
quite a bit and are making a very
positive impact so thank you very much
and stay safe and stay healthy
thank you very much you all invited me
to the negative
thank you
[Music]